[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's been
watching the newest marvel show like a
hawk and this video we're going to be
breaking down all the easter eggs hidden
details story and also discussing what
we think is going to be happening in the
future heavily based on the map fraction
run of the same name it follows kate
bishop played by haley steinfeld as she
teams up with klimp on when we last saw
clint he was talking to wonder at the
end of end game and then an image of him
in the ronin costume was shown to elena
bulova in the post-credits scene of
black widow the costume becomes
extremely important in these first two
episodes but as always we start with the
marvel studios logo there have been some
slight updates to it including chongqi
who now appears in the m right as the
text comes into view as for the episode
we actually start all the way back in
2012 namely new york right as the
chittari invasion begins the orangy
yellow overlay of the air actually pulls
directly from the colour scheme of the
comic covers and we'll talk about how
the title sequence leans into it too
here we're introduced to kate bishop and
early on see not only her trophies for
archery but also her fencing one which
somewhat plays into episode 2. kate in
the comics was highly trained in fencing
and it's nice that it keeps showing up
throughout the entire show now we also
see her rock climbing and doing a
handstand which sort of foreshadows her
climbing up the bell tower later on kate
overhears her mother eleanor and father
james who are arguing about how they
have to sell the penthouse due to their
debts james doesn't want to do this and
eleanor says that a solution isn't gonna
just fall out of the sky this ends up
being ironic as the penthouse is
attacked and later on we can see that
they've kept it so i'm guessing that
james's life insurance is something stop
them from having to move out the
argument is interrupted when kate seave
dropping is picked up and her dad visits
her in a scene that's sort of
reminiscent to the i love you 3001 from
avengers endgame similar to tony this is
the last conversation that james has
with his daughter and they once more
bring up things not just magically
falling from the sky which yeah subtext
for you guys there now he instills in
her the idea that the only control we
have in life is how we deal with the
things that are thrown at us and the
choices that we make the death of her
father very much leaves an empty spot in
her life and i think this is why she
gravitates so much towards clint this
idea of father figures also comes in the
form of a new stepdad and the themes of
parents are clearly laced throughout the
opening two entries we also see a
stuffed dog toy potentially
foreshadowing the dog later on and
weirdly though it's clearly there in
kate's room when she returns to it it's
gone but no
it couldn't be him could it
elena shows that she's a crack shot too
by catching some food in her mouth and
it is possible that down the line they
might reveal that she's the villain
behind it all i know marvel studios
don't always lean into the comics as it
would make it so easy to predict all the
secrets and reveals but there might be
some clues that we can take from the
source material in the comics elena was
the one who apparently died and not
kate's father however she popped up
years later and it was revealed that she
was actually behind the activities of
madame mask now potentially they've
combined the characters and it is
possible that ellen or a mask are one in
the same but we'll talk about that later
on in the video just in the same way
that one division showed us the chaos
that would come from the blip hawkeye
gives us a view of what the battle of
new york would be like for a citizen in
the scene they do an incredible one-shot
take through the house in which kate
looks for her parents there's also great
use of purple in the surroundings which
later becomes a signature colour of kate
during this highly traumatic experience
kate is saved by hawkeye and we see the
moment that he jumps off the side of a
skyscraper from another angle not only
was this the opening panel in the comics
but it was also a big moment in the
avengers film and to add to this we know
from the trailers that it's going to be
happening again but this time with
clinton kate the loss of her dad coupled
with seeing hawkeye saving her life
clearly has a big impact on kate and we
then cut to her father's funeral
potentially they might reverse the lns
situation and have james be the one who
fakes his death but that's of course
just a fan theory and we know how they
tend to turn out now the funeral scene
really brings kate and her mother
together and the full map vows to
protect them worried that something like
the attack could happen again she
dedicates her life to training and we
see as she progresses through the airs
as a skilled archer and swordsman we
watch as she goes from third place to
first and she also learns karate it's
easily my favorite title sequence from a
marvel series so far and it brilliantly
uses similar iconography to the map
fraction run with lots of purples lilacs
violets blues and blacks to orchestrate
the stew hero you also catch stain tower
in the intro before we cut to it in live
action i'm not too up to speed on my new
york geography but i couldn't find this
place on google so potentially it's a
nod to oh but i a stain though he is
disgraced in the marvel universe so i
don't know if they'd name a school after
him now let me know in the comments
below and whilst you're down there can
you please click the thumbs up button
and also subscribe as we're gonna be
doing weekly breakdowns on the show and
we've got our episode 2-1 dropping later
on today now here we catch kay climbing
up a building in order to ring a giant
bell after losing a day after the first
shot doesn't work she adds a clip to the
tennis ball and this somewhat
foreshadows the trick arrows that we
know she and clint will be using later
on in the series this also actually
pulls directly from the comics and in
them they ended up using several trick
arrows in order to fight against the
tracksuit mafia who show up later on the
bell swings loose and ends up destroying
the tower and because of this kate is
expelled from school on manhattan island
we cut to central station and this is
actually where the famous avengers
assemble moment happened in the 2012
film at the top of the building we can
also catch the first responders monument
which was put there after the battle of
new york to commemorate all those that
helped and gave their lives during the
attack like the graphic novel the series
is going to be set at christmas and it's
got a lot of similar iconography to
what's in the original run we join the
bartons who are seeing rogers the
musical a broadway show about captain
america and the battle of new york
showing how much its legacy still hangs
over the city there's some great
taglines for it such as an all-american
musical for an all-american hero and we
can also see one that reads a timeless
story of a timeless hero steve rogers is
actually nicknamed the man out of time
and the poster for it looks somewhat
similar to the broadway show hamilton
captain america of course performed the
star-spangled man with a plan throughout
the country during the second world war
and this was very much a comment on how
he was used in real life to sell war
bonds captain america has always been
somewhat of a tool of propaganda and the
character has been commercialized over
and over to put out certain ideas hell
even falcon in the winter soldier was
literally about what captain america
meant and we hear how he's been twisted
once more the bridge just outside of
central station is the backdrop and we
can also catch a cardboard cutout of
loki flying through the air on the back
of a chittari drone ship which you might
remember from the avengers clint pulls a
bit of a face at that because in the
movie he fired an arrow at loki at that
point and he caught it but then it
exploded the mock-up of the avengers is
hilarious and you have hulk basically
just being a green guy in a hoodie with
face paint on i think the thor and tony
ones are the best though and cap
hilariously sings about how he can do
this all day i love how iron man also
takes off and the character did this at
several points in the film inspiring
this pose make sure you hulk smash that
like button as well there's also
potentially the waitress from the
deleted scene of the avengers who
appeared at the end they also have a guy
with a pymtech logo on and i think that
might be ant-man as hawkeye says he
wasn't even there however it's black
widow who brings back bad memories for
clint and both he and she were of course
trying to sacrifice themselves so that
the other could live and take the soul
stone clint watched her die and it's
clearly stuck with him in many ways kate
represents him right in the wrongs of
him losing a female sidekick though he
doesn't seem that pleased about it from
the first two episodes now from here we
learned that clint also has a hearing
aid and this pulls directly from the
comics as in the matt fraction run he
was starting to go deaf up until that
point even though hawkeye was a normal
guy he was still regarded as a superhero
whereas that run completely
deconstructed him he was going through a
divorce losing his hearing and it
massively grounded him and made him a
landlord that had to put up with a lot
of crap in episode 2 we learned that he
doesn't know exactly when this happened
but lots of exposure to explosions has
clearly caught up to him clint ends up
leaving after a girl who has a widow
ponytail wig on waves at him and this
was similar to how she had her hair when
she died in the bathroom we also see
some graffiti left behind that says
thanos was right that i swear i didn't
put there even though i say eight times
an hour now clint seems to nod almost
almost like yeah he has a point and if
you've seen eternals then you'll know
that the guy may have actually been
doing the world a big favor he's asked
for a selfie by a fan and though it's
clear he's been turned into a celebrity
he doesn't want to be one this is a guy
who was an assassin and marksman for
many years and he's just not ready for
the commercialization of his image he
and the family decide to go to a chinese
restaurant for a succulent chinese meal
and bloody hell i thought that lad got
snapped guys showed up at 30 years old
yeah me now at central station kate
arrives and she returns home to find her
mother in the penthouse with her new
fiance jack jack not only is a similar
name to james but he's also got slicked
back hair and a moustache whilst her dad
had a goatee clearly he's been chosen
because of his similarities but it rubs
kate the wrong way and when they hide
the engagement it just gets more
annoying than when i start pedaling the
same mephisto joke that i've been
running into the ground for over a year
now
now it turns out that jack has moved in
whilst kate has been at school and
there's swords now throughout the house
which he's obsessed with this
foreshadows him attempting to buy
clint's sword later on in the episode
and in episode 2 he also shows off some
of his fencing skills so i love how the
theme has kept up with him we later
learned that his surname is to kane and
if you're familiar with the comics then
you'll know jack stu kane was known as
the swordsman in the source material he
actually met clint as a child and he's
the person that trained him to be an
expert in melee weapons it's gonna be
interesting to see if this is brought
over to the show i think this would be a
really interesting reveal later down the
line in the restaurant scene we get
somewhat of an appearance by laura aka
clint's wife played by linda cortellini
also i'm sure you already know but just
in case you don't lila is played by ava
russo aka anthony russo's daughter so
all you need to do kids if you want to
be in a marvel movie is have your dad
direct some of the biggest films of all
time now clint's normality is once more
broken by a waiter who gives him some
free food for saving the city we then
cut across to see a party and judicate
stress she's confused as a waitress but
this later allows her to sneak into a
secret auction the auction is somewhat
based on the matt fraction run but
instead of clint's costume and sword in
that it was a tape that the villains
were after in the comics clint
apparently assassinated a dictator and
it was caught on camera and then this
vhs was auctioned off on the black
market there were several interested
parties including kingpin and kate
actually disguised herself as madame
mask in order to sneak in if eleanor is
masked then she could have been holding
the auction and this would explain why
she's not there as she wouldn't need to
buy the things if she's selling them so
lots of similarities namely how kate
uses a costume to get into the auction
and edit our items which are linked
towards clint stark aside however where
the big change is is that no one knows
that clint was the ronin whereas in the
comics it was clearly him on the tape he
also appeared in the ronin costume at
one point kind of tying in with this too
to bring everything across in a really
cohesive way at the party we also meet
jack's uncle armand duquesne who
threatens eleanor and he winds up dead
again she may not be behind this as
there are of course the theories that
it's kingpin jacks or potentially that
little punk almond i know it was you kid
i know it was you you punk now almond
actually pulls from the comics and in
those he was jack's father on his 18th
birthday he gave jax a sword and told
him the story of the crimson cavalier
which inspired him to go on to become
the swordsman almond was girl at one
point in order to draw his son out which
may or may not be similar to the plot
line that we're getting here now kate
ends up leaving the party and outside
she comes across a one-eyed dog in the
comics this dog belonged to ivan of the
tracksuit mafia and it was hit by a car
ivan abandoned it and the first issue
revolved around clint saving its life he
took it to the vets and we learned that
it was actually called arrow but because
it was too on the nose he ended up
changing it to lucky lucky also lost its
eye like what we see and we actually got
a full issue from its perspective he ate
a pizza out the box much like this entry
and judging by the posters and cast
lists he's gonna be named pizza dog
which is something that cake called him
in the original run back at the party
kate catches on mon threatening her
mother and eleanor down plays even
knowing what it's about i got a lot of
sharon carter vibes from this and though
it's possibly a misdirect it does give
her the motive to kill him k follows him
to a secret black market auction like
what we see in the comics and the ronin
and blade are put on sale the blade
would never retract like that and still
fit in the handle but we did see
something similar with razor fist who
too had a retractable one in chongqi
jack also gives armin some cheek and
they bid over the sword which we learn
was recovered from the avengers compound
this was of course destroyed in endgame
and hawkeye carried it with him through
the final battle where they didn't put
two and two together with it being from
the avengers hq i will learn that clint
also fought several mob bosses in the
city this could potentially introduce
kingpin if the rumors are true and i'd
absolutely love it if he showed up in
this series and matt murdock showed up
in spiderman no way home now it also
explains why val wants him dead and
clearly he got up to a lot of things
during those five years that we don't
know about now armond ends up winning
the sword and when the suit is brought
out the auction is attacked by the
tracksuit mafia these are some of the
main antagonists from the map fraction
run and they own an apartment block that
extort those that live there led by ivan
they say bro all the time which is also
something that's carried over to the
dialogue here bro now the first episode
of loki also had a scrolling in a
tracksuit in the tva waiting room so who
knows we might even get that touched
upon in this series though i do kind of
doubt it whilst everything is going on
kate ends up grabbing the suit and we
learn that the mafia are after a watch
from avengers hq i'm not sure exactly
what this is but potentially it might
have some iron man armor in it like what
we saw in civil war or it might just be
a nice timepiece kate puts on the
costume and she kicks the crap out of
the mafia before they chase her through
the wine cellar and she's able to make
her escape the mafia have clearly had
run-ins with the ronin before as they
recognize this costume instantly outside
after they discover the watch lucky who
i'm just calling that because of the
comics bites one of the mafia and
together he incapably through the
streets lucky is almost hit by a car
similar to the comics but kate manages
to save him and together the pair make
it out whilst the police arrive it's
also at this point that i believe we see
causey who's a psychopath from the map
fraction run that dated kate in the
comics he also worked for kingpin and
was somewhat of a psychotic clown might
not be him but that's who i'm guessing
he is based off the rumors now back at
clint's hotel room we watch as the
bartons have just returned from the
rockefeller center on the news we see an
anchor that you might recognize and he's
appeared in a number of mcu films
including the end of far from home in
which he introduced jay jonah jameson
during this report clint realized that
someone is taking up his mantle and we
get flashes of his scene from avengers
end game in which we saw him take down a
mob single-handedly kate returns to her
apartment and gives the dog some pizza
before heading out to almonds and she
discovers some butterscotch candy as
well as oni's body he was stabbed in the
back by the looks of it which is of
course a sign of betrayal and yeah i'm
just i'm just saying it's eleanor
because that's the most obvious one to
me okay it heads down to the night and
the mafia arrived once more potentially
introducing ivan as the leader like the
comics he's wearing a black track suit
so i think this is probably the
character though he has hair anyway they
swarm kate but clint arrives donning
some of a homemade ninja costume and he
takes them out before they flee we end
the episode with clinton asking her and
if you've seen the second entry then
you'll know that the two are pairing up
i want to talk about that more on my
breakdown for the second one instead of
just jumping ahead though so make sure
you subscribe as we're going to be
dropping that later on now as for my
thoughts on the episode honestly i was a
bit disappointed in it and outside of
maybe the first episode of one division
i think this is the weakest of the mcu
shows so far it had a brilliant opening
sequence and title scene and then
unfortunately it started to mean effort
for quite a while and just didn't really
get going up until the end
i don't want to give my full review
episode 2 just yet but i had a lot of
the same issues with that and i'm really
hoping that the series picks up i was
talking to greg alba over at real
rejects and he said that it just kind of
feels like a netflix show instead of a
disney plus one which i definitely agree
with lots of unnecessary and low-key
plot points and though i think they did
a great job of introducing kate i think
they didn't really give her all that
much to do now i don't know what the
general feeling for this show is as i'm
recording this before it's been released
online but i think based off this and
the second episode that this may end up
being the weakest mcu series thus far
which kind of sucks as the graphic novel
is amazing helly seinfeld is really
carrying the show and now jeremy rena is
doing the best with what he has i'm not
sure if they're quite nailing what makes
people like his character in the comics
and movies either way let me know your
thoughts below and what you think of the
show and as i've said 500 times i'll be
back later on with another breakdown now
we're earning a competition right now
and giving away three copies of zack
snyder's cc trilogy on the 30th of
november and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the spiderman norway
home trailer which will be linked on
screen right now there's lots of really
cool things happening in it and a couple
of little mistakes are kind of hint
towards some big spoilers for the movie
if not then thanks for sitting through
this video and hopefully i see on the
next one take care peace